administration refusing to call the
migrant situation a crisis
despite thousands flocking to the
southwest border officials even
admitting they're struggling to house
everyone looking for asylum griff
jenkins our man on the border is live in
mcallen texas with an exclusive look
inside what they're calling a migrant
processing center griff
yeah pete you see right there that bus
leaving that white bus they've been
coming
nearly every hour since we've been out
here for the last four
hours and they're holding hundreds if
not thousands of migrants throughout the
day we're going to give you the numbers
in a minute but if you look back this
way
this gate right here in the rio grande
valley sector in mission texas
this is ground zero for biden's border
crisis
and it just came down this road now we
had to pull our drone out of the sky
pete because
a storm just popped up here in the last
10 minutes but we want to show you
exclusive photos that we obtained from a
temporary
outdoor processing site now it is up
this road
you can see here the thousands of
migrants here
in the bus we just showed you coming out
of here you see one in the photo there
they're loading them up that is
literally at the point of contact right
after they've illegally crossed
the river and traditionally they don't
need that but yet the numbers
are so overwhelming that they're having
to set something up to separate the
family units from the unaccompanied
children
to the single adults now let us show you
some exclusive numbers we've just gotten
in the last 24 hours
for just this sector alone in the last
24 hours
1 940 individuals were apprehended right
here where you've seen
these photos and in this sector that's
121
872 on the fiscal year 2021
already up 177 percent
on last year now at the white house
national security advisor jake sullivan
had this to say about the escalating
situation
we've made clear that now is not the
time to come to the united states
we are dealing with a circumstance in
which we have to build the capacity to
be able to assess the asylum claims of
individuals who arrive here
and we have to deal with the obvious
public health effects of a pandemic
now we asked dhs for a statement on
those photos we obtained and really
why they're having to set up these
processing centers because it's so
intense and such a heavy flow they have
not responded yet to that
but it is part of the reason why we saw
senator cornyn
and congressman cuellar down in laredo
where we were yesterday holding that
meeting
talking to local leaders and one of
those local leaders was a border patrol
agent in laredo sector part of the
border patrol union hector garza
and he says that he's not only
disappointed
in the new administration's policy well
let him hear
hear directly from him here's what he
said
the federal government is complicit in
the alien
uh smuggling that's happening on the
border right now i i think in a way the
federal government
is aiding and abetting the smuggling of
human beings into our country we're
allowing cartels to enrich themselves
and to abuse these people
that are coming from central and south
america
and hector garza also drove home the
point that
every single thing that crosses that
river is controlled by the cartel
there's talk of wristbands
he's seen that they're doing it in an
organized way
the colored wristbands determine where
people go
and it is a problem that they're very
worried that because of that february
number we saw this week
100 441 total encounters on the border
for the month of february
that is four months ahead of where we
saw the crisis
in 2019 and they're worried we're going
to see unprecedented numbers
and it's going to get worse and worse
something that senator cornyn
was making the point of calling it a
category 5
hurricane that we could be headed for
pete jed will
griff you're doing great work down there
if i could a real quick question that
photo that you got us exclusively of
that
processing center whatever you want to
call it if we can put it up on the
screen
i mean that's if this was the trump
administration that would be outdoor
family cages out you know under an
overpass
they're trying to explain it away as a
processing center they haven't really
explained what it is yet
but jake sullivan made clear from the
podium he said they're making it clear
they want to make it clear that the
border is not open
is that the message you're seeing or is
this unlike anything you've seen at the
border before griff
i have never seen anything like this and
that is exactly what
not only every border patrol agent i've
talked to but even democrat congressman
henry cuellar is saying that and he's
calling it a crisis
here in his backyard and that question
pete is extremely important
because the message that the migrants
are getting
is that rather than having to come over
surrender and possibly
get caught and released but yet now
because of these temporary processing
sites
the agents some of them calling it a
reception center for the migrants rather
than a processing center
because as soon as they get across the
river many of them particularly the
family units
are being taken directly to a bus
station and released
mind you not covent tested that falls on
the part
of the local officials in the case of
the city of brownsville we reported
earlier this week
204 migrants have now tested positive
since january 25th
but when you get across that river put
on a bus in the place where we showed
you those
photos just a mile up from the river and
then released directly into a bus
station
they then go to wherever they're headed
in the u.s call home
facebook message home and say hey i made
it it was easy
and that pull factor is the greatest one
that the officials are worried about
griff thanks so much